the report might not have been quite so
graphic in its language
but we did point out that the withdrawal
of the us troops would mean that the uk
and other non-us nato allies were likely
also to pull out noting that the end of
its non-nato mission is likely to result
in security situation deteriorating
and we explicitly invited the government
to comment on that the government's
response at the time was to say
oh yes this is the sort of issue that we
have it's a challenge we have to face
and we don't yet know what the wider
government is going to do
seven months on they'd had plenty of
time to think about it so when you heard
the foreign secretary baroness smith
this week saying
no one saw this coming no one could have
predicted this outcome what did you feel
i've had so many people making contact
this week saying
we knew what was happening on the ground
and that is one of the things that's
most heartbreaking the fact that the
foreign secretary seems not to have
understood the gravity of the situation
is absolutely extraordinary and in our
report back in january we were
absolutely clear that there were very
real dangers
linked to the american withdrawal and we
had said that there should be a pause in
troop withdrawal the government clearly
took
waiting to take a lead from the united
states
yeah and when we've heard from the u.s
president in the last day
uh saying
that before he made the decision he he
spoke to all allies they met and they
agreed we should all be getting out he
also said the uk and allies had a choice
to remain
when we heard the prime minister
speaking in the house of commons this
week and other mps the finger was firmly
being pointed at joe biden this is his
fault there was nothing we could do
about it is that true
i think once the united states decided
to pull out it was very difficult for
the uk and other nato allies to remain
in and have an effective force what we
needed to do was persuade joe biden six
seven months ago that the u.s shouldn't
withdraw until there was a stable
settlement and that should have included
conditionality ensuring that the taliban
if they were to be part of the
government would respect human rights
and that so clearly isn't happening so
those conversations did not take place
as far as we know those conversations
did not take place and the government's
response has consistently appeared to be
we're waiting to see what the united
states is going to do
rather than saying we are telling the
united states that it is vital that we
remain in to secure the peace and
stability of the country
where we have been present for the last
20 years
what about the planning for this
post-withdrawal period the defense
secretary said earlier this week that
the operation was always planned it has
had to be
brought forward
if this was a planned operation it's a
chaotic one isn't it
absolutely
there are so many people
in afghanistan who are fearing for their
lives and
we've known about that for months again
it shouldn't have come as a surprise to
the government people have been lobbying
on behalf of the interpreters on behalf
of locally engaged british council staff
on behalf of journalists for weeks and
months
and the government hasn't been listening
they haven't
sought out those people whose lives are
at risk at a time when they could have
done so now in kabul is so much harder
than it would have been three four weeks
ago far less three four months ago
what about the foreign secretary's
decision to take a holiday abroad at the
time of the the us withdrawal top civil
servants at the foreign office the home
office and the ministry of defense still
on holiday according to reports today
all adding to the feeling that we have
abandoned the people of afghanistan in
their hour of need
that's how it looks
that whatever was going through the
foreign secretary's mind when he went on
holiday as soon as he saw how fast the
cities in afghanistan were falling he
should have been straight on a plane
home and the prime minister should
certainly not have gone on holiday on
saturday
could he have made a difference if he
picked up the phone and spoken to his
afghan counterpart there have been those
who've come out in defense of him saying
that this was a crumbling government
there was nothing that could be done at
the time the foreign secretary has
defended himself today saying that his
focus was on security at kabul airport
but but picking up the phone making that
phone call could it have made a
difference
we can only believe that it would have
made a difference clearly we don't know
we can't rewrite history but making that
phone call trying to ensure that people
whose lives were at
absolute risk could be got to the
airport in kabul before the taliban got
that would have made so much difference
telling people on sunday oh well you can
now apply for the afghan repatriation
scheme isn't sufficient that telling
them on sunday
bring your papers if anything would be a
death sentence as they tried to get to
kabul it was all too late but an earlier
phone call could have made a difference
baroness smith thank you very much
indeed